let's go to JWR from Atlanta Georgia JWR
welcome
great to be here again
um
I was going to ask okay I guess my
general question was how
um I think I've had a phrase this
um how how what's the right what's the
what's the right balance of how much of
how much attention we should be giving
to this whole thing regarding Trump and
the investigation because although
although he's not as much of an F
although he is not as much of an active
threat as he was like say a Europe a
year or two when there was a character
of getting when there was a chance of
getting reelected there is still there
is still the possibility that we might
just blow like just blow him blow him
off ignore it pretend that just act as
though he's not an issue anymore so like
what's the right balance we should be
what's the right balance to strike well
listen if it's not made clear if it has
to be made clear that what Trump did is
humiliatingly Criminal and unacceptable
because if everybody just stays quiet
about it and doesn't talk about the fact
that you know he's got dumps of
documents all over his apartment then it
actually makes it more plausible that
voters will vote for him again in 2024
they really really need to be brutally
humiliated into not even considering
supporting the guy in 2024 now I know
that there are Republicans who are
saying oh the Mar-A-Lago raid is the
best thing that could have happened to
Trump I've seen no real evidence of that
so far
oh well no not so far hopefully it's not
that way
also
um am I only allowed one question well
it depends what it is let's hear the
second one
um do you think that there is a chance
that better men could potentially screw
up the lead he has over over Dr Oz in
the senate race in Pennsylvania but so
far things look good but do you think
there do you think that there is a
chance that they might potentially screw
this up in like the debates yeah I mean
listen you can always screw it up it's
it's looking very solid for fetterman
right now but of course he could screw
it up let's just hope it doesn't happen
oh of course not I mean I'm not saying
that I think he is going to I think he
is in a very good place but not like put
it this way he is winning but he has not
won yet absolutely and I I just yes and
I I just hope that he that that his
campaign which so far has done a pretty
decent job continues to keep it up and
doesn't and doesn't uh I guess
uh blow the blow the three to one leader
they have so far yes I have not seen
that it's three to one but I appreciate
the phone call very very much I believe
what you're referring to is that he's
estimated to have a 75 chance of winning
but not that he's going to win 75 to 25